écoutez c'est une très bonne nouvelle
qu'on ait pu enfin trouver un directeur
pour tromper qu'un triangle parce que
nous avons eu pas mal de candidature
mais qui va qqun qui ne correspondait
pas au profil recherché
effectivement dans la chance lice nous
avons eu entre un chasseur adrien
guillaume gille christophe et manuel
césaire et effectivement c'est le profil
de manuel 6è qui correspondent beaucoup
plus au directeur recherche et au cahier
des charges imposé par enfin par les
membres du jury
le profil recherché c'est son expérience
de direction de guillaume a servi à
compter a pesé absolument manuel césaire
est quand même sur le terrain culturel
depuis quelques années donc son
expérience ses compétences ont été
nécessaires pour le choix définitif
parce que nous avons quand même après le
départ d'assad buiatti de démission et
quand même deux personnes qui parlent
qui porte aussi à la retraite donc c'est
quand même un bâtiment qui fragilise et
et il est il fallait absolument qu'on
trouve quelqu'un qui puisse connaissant
déjà le terrain et connaissant déjà
comment dirais-je les fonctions de
directeur parce qu'il a été quand même
directeur de 2006 à 2010 je crois 2
comment dirais-je du centre de ceux du
centre culturel atrium est donc tout à
fait normal qu'on le choisit parce qu'il
est beaucoup plus comment dirais-je
beaucoup plus avertis
connaissant le terrain et surtout vivant
martignac